big brain welcome everyone to big brain
sky blogs so this is for you really
smart kids who like to go way on up
beyond and do watch science okay
okay again cobblestone generator time
lights go okay I've got to make the
fastest cobblestone generator in the
planet I got a point out that we have
more than one island and the Sun is
moving I think double stone generator
you're doing it let's go okay all right
we did it Ken so what was the time
what was the time there's at least eight
seconds right so all right I'm gonna dig
it three two one go
big fan big braid here we go big brain
oh cool oh wait oh yeah over to pick up
the block put it up there does it
connect anything right no it just shut
up you do lava I do lice okay wait we
gotta put a block in the way here are
they just gonna get robbed we don't do
you know we don't you put it right here
yeah hey why would you listen to me good
question right hey Ken yeah
what did you go in and check out the
sand island oh wait it doesn't exist
oh you're gonna bring that back you're
gonna it's out there now okay yeah we
learned our lesson at one time we've
built this stupid cobblestone generator
like 12 times now he's talking there
no no it's not about getting it right
it's about getting it perfect any big
old doofus can build a cobblestone
generator but and not any big old doofus
can make it in three seconds go
one three seconds baby here we go boom
boom but the Amish moon is that is that
big enough it's big enough for you and
your mama sorry that was that was me I'm
sorry more spot right all right you want
to try this God dang it big brain
[Music]
three seconds baby we are big brains we
got big brains we barely got it what do
you mean we barely got it first try I
see three grew as always you me too
hey we should name treat something
together so it will be like art yeah you
know what we should name it what tree
tree I love it it's so unique yeah how
deep is this is like three that's what
your MA yeah yeah so now we need it we
need tree to drop thing trade good we're
not gonna have any wood unless you drop
some saplings
SAP it up anything nothing we must be
doing something wrong somebody the
comments right now is like only good or
tree sister maybe the 480
okay cool yeah yeah yeah baby baby oh my
gosh I'm freaking out okay so anyway the
whole thing already
oh look at you go oh I'm sorry sorry
I'll explain four small brain so right
now what I'm doing can I'm making a
cobblestone generator Rhynie what we
need to throw out so that like generates
like an empty amount of cobblestone
that's right but if you're no careful
you could actually miss you could
actually burn down the whole tree their
whole tree Wow
but that's how it'll be terrible small
people do that the only sway I mean help
do I put it here together no no don't
worry
okay alright watch this cobblestone
generator
[Music]
it's already wrong already give me their
water give me the water cane all right
you're bringing all the weeds out of me
right now I just make me wheeze put the
thing I'll put the thing okay oh I'm
sorry did I just make a cobblestone
generator I'm sorry why did you even
pick it up - whatever
okay it's fine oh I'm sorry fine when I
do it all the time it is so I'm gonna
dig some dirt if I look up there the
trees on fire again are the cobblestone
generator is gone I'm gonna be bearing
with your generator is locked solid okay
it's but I can mind this right now right
mining it with my hands this is what we
used to do in Sweden in the Stone Age
right right hey maybe oh my god good job
of it see it's screwed up again why
would you ever think that I would mess
anything up maybe we'll get back up you
know here talking to you again I think
yeah I know I'm talking to I know
exactly I'm talking to that's right you
know that's what another noble price is
a Swedish invention because we were so
smart that we decided other people need
some words for smartness and who got the
first awarded you could give it to
yourselves we gave it to you know what
I'm not gonna answer that either Oh
what how does that what happened oh I
get it
it needs to be ah oh you're gonna feel
so stupid now Ken
how about gonna feel stupid I feel like
we're going backwards maybe okay this is
actually all the space we need yeah
eight times now okay okay wider than me
be sure I'm acting very confident but
it's working so far see how easy it is
ken the water's like flowing backwards
is that right is that this first flow
technique that [ __ ] did you know about
this okay all right I'm impressed
I'm impressed I'm not gonna lie I didn't
know in Mississippi they practice that
technique but okay we do we try say I
don't know what you do in Alabama I'm
not gonna ask questions
oh yeah we're gonna be next Texas do you
think any more states can you just
google it no yeah yeah oh yeah I
definitely have not been googling it
[Music]
under the tree okay I think I know what
I'm doing allow me to help you you know
exact you minecraft pros here uh-huh
thank you
we're about to show you and the way
you've never seen a cobblestone
generator ever built before this is what
we used to do back in my day instead
while all you kids were busy playing for
tonight all right in winning millions of
dollars Somalia what is this any more
dirt sorry my brain capacity is max you
can't you can't think and talk right
guys that's why I'm talking right now
all right this is safe okay II need like
either you do the water thingy I do the
lobby okay you need me to break it we've
taken up most of our little island with
the cobblestone generator but that's
okay it's called the side swede back in
my hood Zach back in your hood yeah you
have the rest of the wood er I'll get ya
get - thanks bro
yeah bro I got you oh it would seem I'm
on fire that's fine so many people made
fun of me in one of the videos because I
caught on fire and jumped off the edge
I'm so glad you brought that up because
I looked at that and I'm like what
that's big brain that's big brain right
there you're on fire there's some water
next to you what do you do Joyce waited
go pokey dokey hopefully this works
oh gosh Ken what is is this gonna break
it again oh let me give you watch I want
to see it okay
does these need to go down maybe you can
trust me this is gonna break only one
way to find out
Cirie's it over thank you for watching
everybody watching there's like an easy
how to like a point the first one are
you looking up no you need to look I do
[Music]
oh well you were busy doing that I did
that yeah good already you know what
it's it's working so far and I don't
think it's gonna mess up the
cobblestones the cobblestone generator I
think we're good what's the other one
okay well we get back to my dad how are
you on fire what did you see
I did not right-click like an old man
over here okay I'm just like I think I'm
having a small brain day yeah I've heard
of these they happen they happen through
your average Joe air from time to time
you start digging every time and somehow
I messed it up no I'm like like yeah I'm
doing good down here and then it's just
gone alright it's fine
this time the lava is shaped lava yeah
that looks safe it's state has to be
same Sweden is that that what you guys
say huh pulling off this is not safe is
okay you got water just swim back up
changing the cobblestone generator that
you worked so hard to build you are
doing a very good job keep it up look at
that I actually did Wow and bonus lava
bonus lava right so now if I dig it
[Applause]
yeah good job thanks bro Wow Wow why you
do this absolutely goes down 3d doesn't
it it's fine you have to do that I'm
just wanting it say I'm just playing it
safe the waters not flowing up there
thank me we fun doing great team works
okay yes here's here's a thing for small
brains in case you don't know you can
make slabs ah she's a bargain piece of
art no no no
all right putting their output in there
and you've been the bridge to whatever
island you wanted all right what island
okay so there's water over the air maybe
there's food over there cuz we're gonna
oh we're gonna be swayed honey wait wait
wait wait wait is the but the Sun is
moving it's just always having to reset
so much fun playing forever oh there's
an apple there's something ok so there's
some Oh got one yeah yeah oh I got an
apple oh yeah okay so apples there's
rule to trees I'm ear everyone complain
about it I need like space to grow but
they were giving constructive criticism
yes constructive is it did exactly
exactly big miss there's one thing we've
learned from this this is how we are
we're gonna we're gonna mess it up
eventually why I don't know what you do
at some point it's all gonna go wrong
what are you talking about I don't know
what's gonna happen but somehow the
cobblestone generator is gonna break my
couples don't generate they're live
forever this is how I speak American on
my accent because I'm Swedish that's big
brain speak what do you mean what have
you ever spoken with a Swedish accent
but five years ago babies all the time
mean yeah I mean is my favorite our luvs
means good cuz that's what they are
called and why you laugh I don't know I
think rain slimes yeah you haven't made
it to island yet Wow pathetic
very really understand Swedish there
must say that do we in the drop of
Minecraft become delirious can I place
as well if you had big brain maybe Oh
oh not today big brain you out to brain
me one time
there's villagers over there really I
don't think we good
alright sheriff I I mean we got a
cobblestone generator we go if we make a
bed we can make villagers Frank and they
make tiny village yeah I'll go you say
it was like making boy this is how you
speak minecraft Ken right big brain
money you gotta you gotta you gotta get
ass big time really big brains right I'm
not gonna - because I mean money right
now we're not even getting ways that be
ouch why do you hit me
ah Paul as the builders would say
whether frickin
should we go maybe it's a bad island no
we should we should definitely meet dad
there's nether stuff over there right
glowstone and I wish I saved some stones
I'm just so excited that we're actually
doing it we still got a Jake
you only have one stone yeah oh my god
oh yes that means bad guy come soon no
actually a lot of people don't notice
but bad guys need a 5 by 5 square to
spawn so can't spawn here but later what
we can do is we can make an island that
is 5 by 5 and we can use that to get the
resources from yeah brain is at mainly
large right now very big it'll cool me
be brain for nothing big brain big arms
big brain no he just ran off the edge
and dad can you pushed him oh you pushed
him oh this one's looking at me and
judging me
no are you serious went off the edge
why did he went off the edge again when
he was fine yeah I just he was like you
don't want to live anymore and he did
he'd left
oh then we go do we have to have him I
am making sure he's not going anywhere
we don't have another one how we gonna
make ah what did the villages where they
use for it like freaking out man
did we need him for something well we
can make them freak and we can give them
professions and then we can trade
something it seems like pretty like late
in the game that you would do something
like that but stay here okay good wait
State okay right okay I also got some
wheat seeds so we can grow wheat so this
is going really really good I think
trying to expand the land that's what
you Americans do don't you
yep that's right well I mean written
really right
oh you blame yeah
yes got like a rhythm going
did did you do today I'm building to the
other Island because I think I see Mike
my blocky way we could made the
workbench they don't have to Frick but
technically now since you kill one we
can't expand the village maybe one will
magically reappear yeah maybe he'll just
like photosynthesis will they call it
new you want to see what I did over
there no you want to fight me on bridge
no all da and I have stuff
oh wait it's like it's like when you're
playing a horror game you guys got a
look okay cool so you did you did
oh he's in there yeah Rosen there is fun
actually if we like it yeah I think he's
I think he's he's enjoying it too you're
gonna you're gonna take him out and
build him back in to get that one block
of dirt hey guy hi gonna starve to death
like that all right now they don't start
okay look there's a water pool oh no oh
no I'm dying he's gonna be saved that
precious precious dirty face is dirt
precious dirt we put the trees over here
yeah that would make sense
yeah okay all right I'm gonna make
something you never had
oh-ho oh that's true I didn't the rabble
owes me great woman
see that's the joke that was the joke
cool let's go plant Island okay you got
the sample is everything okay
Oh grab bucket while you're at it bro oh
okay bro I got bucket oh and grab the
apples barri at it though in case you
ate them all they're not in there did
you just accuse me yes she just accused
me yes I'm accusing you did she just
take juice yeah I keep like I have I'm
missing two chicken bones right now and
you ain't like five apples in a row I
don't know what your problem is I was
why are you so hungry I was really
hungry why is the grass not growing oh
my god oh it is it is it is there
another thing I guess Oh
Oh what's your wow hello oh you're gonna
come in here hey hey is everyone up for
that for me don't be a third wheel again
Eddie you got some privacy
oh yes it wasn't ok gamer good we got
all the island set up we have three
trees some weed and man are we doing
good yeah we're doing great let us know
how great we're doing and how you do
things sure they have already can small
brains like coyote element that's right
before these videos even over with we
they've already told us all about it
what you never played toupper simulator
you know it's fun right I'm not supposed
to give my opinion but give it a try
and then you can tell me if it's good or
not convinced yet ok I'll cut you a deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]